this video is brought to you by nebula
watch episode 2 right now by signing up
with the link in the
description late on a spring evening
1992 the Endeavor space shuttle on its
Maiden flight stood on its Launchpad in
Cape canaval Florida
the crew sitting aboard ready to take on
a daring
Mission a Rendevous between two
spacecraft in orbit a rescue mission
Bruce Melnick was aboard that day the
challenge we had was that uh this
satellite was never supposed to be
touched by human hands once it got in
orbit it was supposed to be way up in
geosynchronous orbit you know over
22,000 miles up but it launched on an
unmanned rocket that failed to fire
second stage and send it on its way so
it was stuck in a useless 800 M High
orbit Melnick and his crewm mates were
about to take the ride of their life to
rescue the satellite to grab it with
their bare hands and attach a new second
stage but before that could happen a
complicated series of events was about
to take place beneath them three liquid
fuel rocket engines were about to burst
into life with furious power that would
tilt the entire structure off axis held
back by just eight explosive bolts fed
with turbo pumps driving fuel out of the
external fuel tank slung underneath the
Orbiter meanwhile the two massive solid
rocket boosters lay dormant the two
largest solid Rockets ever made to date
and when the signal that the Orbiter
engines were up to the challenge arrived
an inferno would be lit inside them
causing the entire colume of solid
rocket fuel inside to erupt lifting the
Revolutionary reusable space Plane off
the ground and to orbit
this is the insane engineering of the
Space
Shuttle we are mere minutes away from
launch helium and nitrogen have purged
the main engines the flight surfaces and
Main engine gimbals have been tested the
shuttle is now fully fueled and under
its own power no longer connected to the
Launchpad 10 seconds are left sparkler
like igniters fire underneath the engine
to burn any stray hydrogen as the
shuttle prepares to open the main fuel
valve liquid hydrogen begins to race
through the fuel lines pushed by the
pressure of the tanks through the engine
nozzles where it begins to expand and
turn into gas this gaseous hydrogen
drives a low pressure turbopump turbine
elevating the rate of flow of hydrogen
through the fuel lines this is all
happening in the blink of an eye less
than a second later the main oxidizer
valves open unlocking the fuels true
Power Fuel and oxygen meet in the two
high-press turbo pumps raising flow
rates even higher back in the nozzle we
see our first Flames oxygen levels are
still low and combustion instabilities
cause the engines to rattle but the
engine is now ready to enter its next
stage entering open loop engine control
no longer controlled by a prescripted
startup sequence instead the engine
constantly monitors pressure readings
and adjust valves according ly the
engine begins to throttle up oxygen
valves continually opening wider the
flame transitions from a low press
orange flame to an eerie hot blue the
space shuttle is unique in that these
engines are not directly under the fuel
tanks the expensive rocket engines were
attached to the reusable shuttle not the
Expendable external tank and because the
main engines are offset from the solid
rocket boosters which are holding you to
the pad when we light off the main
engines that 7 Seconds it actually bends
that stack over and you can feel this
little lurching back and forth NASA
calls it twang it's kind of a real
technical term the only thing stopping
the entire shuttle from tipping over at
this point are the holdown posts
attached to the solid rocket boosters
which for now lay dormant waiting for
the signal to ignite the pressure inside
the diverging nozzle is still lower than
atmospheric pressure and as a result we
can see a flow separation layer which
gradually creeps to the edge of the
nozzle as the pressure inside increases
3 seconds on launch the engines are
checked to ensure they are running at
90% of their rated thrust the time has
come for the solid rocket boosters to
ignite the solid rocket boosters are 45
M long and are filled to the brim with
solid rocket fuel a rubbery mixture that
combines both the fuel and oxidizer into
one solid material the oxidizer ammonium
per chlorate mixes up nearly 70% of the
mixture while 16% was the aluminium fuel
we need a way to ignite the entire colum
quickly the igniter itself was
essentially a miniature solid rocket
motor which itself was ignited by an
even smaller miniature solid rocket
motor to ensure extremely quick
combustion this main igniter was shaped
with a 40o stair orifice when it comes
to solid rocket Motors the more surface
area available to burn the quicker it
will burn rapidly producing the heat and
pressure needed to ignite the entire
colume of solid propellant once this
happened there was no turning back so
there were several safety mechanisms in
the arming sequence to prevent it
happening accidentally the first part of
the arming sequence began when
technicians accessed the safety and
arming device in the top skirt of the
solid rocket booster here to remove a
pin this pin locked a safety device
device in place preventing it from
rotating into an armed position by
accident when it was rotated into
position on command at tus 5 minutes it
connected a standard NASA Detonator
through a tunnel to the igniter system
when it fires it begins the rapid chain
of events that brings the space shuttle
to its highest thrust but the entire
rocket is still anchored to the
Launchpad held down by the hold down
posts four on each Solid Rock ET booster
these holdown posts anchor the solid
Rockets to the ground through the AFT
skirt with massive 700 and 11 mm long
and 88 mm wide bolts the Lower Side of
the bolt is tensioned using a regular
nut while the upper nut is a special
kind of explosive knot a frangible knot
on two occasions two of these frangible
nuts did not fracture correctly
something NASA described as stud
Hang-Ups these these issues did not stop
the space shuttle from taking off with
the power of two solid rocket boosters
and three main engines one or two
improperly fractured nuts were not going
to stop the space shuttle from taking
off these holdown posts were primarily
designed to prevent the space shuttle
from tipping over while the three main
engines were brought up to Full Throttle
or simply by a gust of wind however if
four or more of these stud Hang-Ups
occurred the issue could have been
Mission critical and so a redesign was
introduced for sts1 126 where a
crossover assembly was included this new
system linked the two pyrotechnic
charges in each nut to ensure they
detonated within 50 microsc of each
other a delay of up to 250 micros was
possible with the previous design and
this was identified as the main issue
causing the socalled stud Hang-Ups the
shuttle is now free with the largest and
most powerful solid Rockets ever used in
human space flight powering it upwards
each of the solid rocket boosters
provided 13,000 kons of thrust each
nearly double that of the Falcon 9 first
stage but the very notion of using solid
rocket boosters for a crude space
shuttle was initially met with extreme
concern using solid rocket boosters for
human space light had never been
attempted before they were nearly
exclusively used for military use like
the minute man ICBM the solid rocket
fuel allowed them to stand ready
available to launch in a moment's notice
however once ignited there is little
that can be done to stop them the entire
colume of propellant is ignited at once
there are no pumps or valves that can
lower the fuel and oxidizer being
delivered once ignited they stay ignited
until all of the propellant is expended
this of course comes with extreme
control issues that need to be
engineered neared around to begin the
engine needs to be throttled back as it
expends fuel as fuel is used the weight
of the rocket lowers if the thrust isn't
lowered the rocket could exceed its Max
allowable Dynamic pressure and
disintegrate an improperly designed fuel
colume could make matters even worse as
a simple circular internal cavity will
result in an increase in thrust as the
fuel is burned however many different
thrust profiles can be achieved with
different shapes a pointed star cavity
will start with higher thrust thanks to
the increased surface area but rapidly
decreases in thrust as the points of the
star burn down and the surface area
decreases this effect can be increased
by increasing the number of points on
the stair which is why the igniter had
40 nearly every illustration online
shows the space shuttle solid rocket
boosters with A continuous cylinder if
this was the design of the fuel Channel
it could have caused issues the surface
area of a circular internal cavity would
have increased as fuel was burned
because the cavity's diameter and
circumference would be increasing this
was not how the solid rocket boosters
were designed the upper section of the
solid rocket booster had an 11 pointed
stair shape this shape was created with
this mandrel placed inside the upper
section before the fuel mixture was
poured in the shape then transitioned
into a circular section however it
wasn't constant in diameter the diameter
increased towards the nozzle this design
provided elevated thrust at ignition
when it was needed most and then reduced
gradually to lower the maximum Dynamic
pressure the space shuttle experienced
with the thrust decreasing by 33% 5
seconds into the flight when filling the
solid rocket booster segments with the
propellant they were filled in in Paris
matching with its contemporary segment
on the other booster this allowed the
two segments to be filled using the same
batch of fuel mixture so if there were
any inconsistencies in the mix they
would be at the very least consistent on
the left and right side of the shuttle
ensuring differential thrust from the
boosters would not drive it off course
however all five of the nozzles were
capable of thrust factoring to control
the space shuttle during ascent and
eight 80% of the steering power came
from the solid rocket boosters thanks to
their power and increased distance from
the central axis of the Space Shuttle
the space shuttle's aerodynamic Flight
Services played no part in control
during Ascent but they did actuate to
reduce aerodynamic stress and drag on
Ascent 7 seconds after takeoff with the
space shuttle traveling around 140 kmph
a roll program is initiated through
asymmetric thrust voring of the nozzles
of the solid rocket boosters with
actuators mounted inside the AF skirt
here there are two hydraulic actuators
on each nozzle to allow it to move in
both pitch and yaw the space shuttle
turns over
180° and pitches 12° off a straight up
trajectory placing the shuttle on a
heading towards its assigned orbit
lowering the dynamic pressure on the
shuttle's wings and providing the flight
crew a view of the Horizon out of their
Windows of course this 108 80° rotation
would not have been needed if the space
shuttle was simply rotated on the
Launchpad but the Launchpad was designed
for the Saturn 5 the position of the
service Tower and all of the supporting
infrastructure associated with it locked
the space shuttle into this orientation
and it was simply easier to program a
roll than to build a new Launchpad 45
seconds into the flight something
fascinating happens the space shuttle
exceeds the speed of sound and the sound
of those rocket engines can no longer
reach the astronauts so you don't hear
those Rocket Motors that much anymore
behind you but now you hear the air
rushing down the side of the shuttle
because you're in the thickest part of
the atmosphere and it sounds like a
train howling through a tunnel when that
air is going across the rough blankets
and tiles on the outside of the shuttle
and as the space shuttle races higher
and higher into the atmosphere and the
air gets progressively thinner even this
sound begins to dwindle away for the
last 15 20 seconds of first stage it's
just a quiet very rough ride because
you're still on the solid rocket
boosters and it will get even quieter as
the solid rocket boosters reach the end
of their fuel supply 2 minutes into the
flight lowering chamber pressures
trigger sensors to begin the separation
process however if these fail a backup
system based simply on time elapsed
takes over once triggered the trust
vectoring system is commanded to return
the nozzles to the neutral position and
the Orbiter is commanded to maintain its
attitude for 4 seconds the Sr RBS are
attached to the external tank at Four
Points through three struts on the lower
section of the rocket and an additional
upper connection each held in place by
frangible connections that are severed
on command at the same time eight
separation motors for on the top of the
solid rocket booster and for in the
bottom fire these were also solid Motors
and provided 96,000 Newtons of thrust
ensuring the srbs safely detached from
the space shuttle as it continued its
flight to orbit this solid rocket
booster separ ation process was the
thing that caught Bruce offg guard most
on his first flight picture this you're
sitting on top of the explosive bolts
that are holding the boosters to the
tank so when those explosive bolts let
go it's a large bang and then the
booster separation motors which are
Little Rocket Motors that fly the
boosters away from the shuttle so it
doesn't Rec contct it those exhausts are
aimed right at your windshield so it's
staging instead of there being this
little pop and off you go in second
stage it's this big bang and then you're
in this Fireball where the exhaust from
the booster set Motors are o over the
windshield and it's like geez did we
just blow up and then very quickly you
know you you get through that and you
can see the nice dark purpleness of
space ahead of you so that's really the
only surprise going a pill that I had on
my first flight at this point the srbs
are continuing to climb in altitude just
slower than the space shuttle upon
reaching their apogee roughly a minute
later they will begin their Journey back
down to earth eventually releasing a
series of parachutes from its nose cone
to slow its descent and land in the
ocean to be recovered and reused
meanwhile the Orbiter is continuing its
journey in its second stage of flight
second stage is smooth matter of fact
most astronauts will call it electric
drive but now is when the G start to
build up and you're getting pushed
further and further back in your seat
and then we throttle the engines back
when we reach 3GS because it is a winged
vehicle so there's a lot of aerodynamics
going on there and you know the for the
structural Integrity we go ahead and
throttle back to 3GS because the wings
could come off if you accelerated a
whole lot more than that and that would
make for a bad day under the power of
the three main engines fed with liquid
hydrogen and liquid oxygen from the
external tank the shuttle continues its
way to orbit this external tank is a bit
of an anomaly the space shuttle was
intended to be fully reusable when it
was first conceived with the fuel and
oxidizer tanks incorporated into the
Orbiter itself in fact the space shuttle
was envisioned in many forms ultimately
funding challenges forced the space
shuttle's ambitious designs to be
simplified and the Air Force was
approached to bolster funds influencing
the design to stray even further from
the original Vision primarily in an
increased cargo bay capacity and
increased Glide range the external tank
was was however the largest compromise
of design gone was the idea of a manned
external tank that would glide back to
land what would have saved money in the
long run simply would have been too
expensive to develop relying instead on
an Expendable external tank a massive
non-reusable structure that would
disintegrate during re-entry the
external tank was Heavy it wasn't simply
two pressurized tanks it was a
structurally integral component
responsible for transmitting enormous
loads is was the centerpiece of the
space shuttle system the structural
backbone connecting to both the solid
rocket boosters and the Orbiter in order
to do this the external tank had to be
strong it was 47 m long and weighed 33.5
metric T empty its aluminium skin is
reinforced with strengthening rings and
stringers this was essentially a massive
thermos flask with a spaced double skin
to insulate the cryogenic fuel inside
finally the entire structure Ure was
covered in a layer of orange insulation
foam which alone weighed 2.2 tons the
first two space shuttle missions
featured a white external tank coated in
a fire retardant latex which was removed
to save a/4 ton of weight the liquid
oxygen tank was located on top of the
external tank it's much smaller than the
liquid hydrogen tank thanks to Oxygen's
much higher density and this is part of
why the liquid oxygen tank was placed on
top of the external tank as it pushes
the Rocket Center of GRA gravity higher
an important aspect of stability in
Flight if a rocket is traveling Straight
Up drag and lift acts through the center
of pressure the location of the center
of pressure is determined by the
location of the aerodynamic surfaces and
engines but the rocket rotates around
the center of gravity which is
determined by the placement of mass
because of this it makes sense to place
weight higher on the rocket as it moves
the center of gravity above the center
of pressure imagine a rocket flying with
its orientation aligned with its
direction of flight when a gust of wind
knocks it off balance it introduces an
angle of attack which creates lift
acting through the center of pressure
and the rocket rotates around the center
of gravity returning the rocket to its
original position if the center of
gravity was below the center of pressure
the opposite would happen and the rocket
would be unstable so the dense liquid
oxidizer was placed on top of the
external tank this came with the added
benefit of allowing the intertank to be
placed higher on the external tank as
the hydrogen tank is much larger the
intertank is a loadbearing structure
between the two tanks there is even a
massive beam hidden within this
intertank resisting enormous compressive
loads as the solid rocket Motors attempt
to push inwards the lower support
holding the solid rocket boosters takes
all of the sheer stress created by the
upwards thrust of the booster and so the
upper support acts primarily in
compression the forward attachment point
to the Orbiter is also located on the
lower portion of the intertank of course
all of this liquid oxidizer and fuel
needed to get to the main shuttle
engines on the Orbiter the liquid oxygen
exits the tank here this pipe is massive
46 CM wide big enough to crawl through
when the liquid oxygen begins to flow it
acts much like water and with this rate
of flow a massive Whirlpool could form
with the weight of all this fluid
swirling and sloshing inside the tank
this could cause massive instability
issues or it could even expose the
outlet and allow bubbles to enter the
engine so antivortex and anti- slashing
baffles are placed on the bottom of this
tank where the oxidizer exits liquid
oxygen travels down this pipe into the
interstage where it exits and runs along
the length of the outside of the liquid
hydrogen tank until it meets the primary
Orbiter connection point this connection
Point connects physically to the Orbiter
but is also the primary connection for
the liquid oxygen and and liquid
hydrogen to the left and right of this
truss connection are two em biblical
plates which ma directly to
corresponding plates on the underside of
the Orbiter the left plate provided a
connection for liquid hydrogen and the
right plate provided a connection for
liquid oxygen each also had gaseous
lines that brought back gaseous hydrogen
and oxygen from the main engine to their
respective tanks this was vital in order
to maintain ulage pressure ulage is the
volume of gas above a liquid storage
tank like the cryogenic liquid oxidizer
and hydrogen tanks the pressure of this
volume has to be maintained as the
liquid lowers if the pressure is allowed
to lower the structural Integrity of the
tanks could be compromised the gaseous
hydrogen used to pressurize the tank was
tapped off from the hydrogen fuel line
after it went through the regenerative
cooling Loops of the nozzle here at the
outlet of the turbine exhaust manifold
of the low pressure fuel pump liquid
oxygen did not pass through this
regenerative cooling system and thus
needs to be converted into a gas to
pressurize the tanks it instead was
tapped off here at the outlet of the
main oxygen turbo pump after passing
through a heat exchanger around the
turbine of this pump finally there were
electrical connections on each plate two
made up of smaller electrical wires that
provided power to the external tank and
solid rocket boosters while also
carrying vital Telemetry data from each
of the orbiters computers finally there
was also the liquid hydrogen
recirculation connection which was only
used during the liquid hydrogen engine
cooldown sequence before launch where
the cryogenic fluid is circulated
through the feed lines Valves and turbo
pumps to bring them down to temperature
if this didn't occur bubbles could form
the time for main engine cut off is
quickly approaching the process will be
triggered by a predetermined velocity
Target around 28,000
kmph however it can be triggered by Fuel
and oxidizer sensors detecting a low
fluid level there are eight propellant
depletion sensors the four fuel
depletion sensors are located on the
bottom of the liquid hydrogen tank
however the liquid oxygen sensors were
located Downstream of the feed line
inside the Orbiter there was also an
extra 500 kg of liquid hydrogen loaded
over the required 6:1 oxidizer fuel
mixture ratio together these ensured
that in the event the main engine was
cut off as a result of propelling
depletion that main engine cut off
occurred in a fuel Rich scenario as
oxidizer Rich engine shutdowns severely
erode and damag the reusable engines the
time has now come for the main engines
to shut down and for the external tank
to separate frangible nuts once again
explode to separate the two structures
the external tank begins to float away
leaving the emical plates underneath the
shuttle exposed and fixing that is the
next challenge you've got a Clos those
doors that's one of the first things you
do and that's very very critical because
if you don't close those doors you can't
re-enter because you'll burn up during
re-entry and so that's one of the things
that we've talked about we've learned
about but nobody has ever really thought
about or no one has ever really come up
with an easy solution if you had to do
an Eva to close those doors how you'd
ever do it you'd have to do a space walk
back to the back here somehow and and
maybe hold on to the
there's just no easy way to get
underneath there to close those but we
talk about it and we come up with some
ideas but never had to be done never had
to be done and there was never a
procedure set to do it thankfully these
doors successfully closed on every
single space shuttle mission the
external tank is now on its way back to
Earth's atmosphere helped Along by a
vent opening in the oxygen tank that
causes the tank to Tumble away from the
Orbiter with the crust of the main
engines gone the astronauts have
instantly become weightless a Serene
moment that filled Bruce with so much
joy that he forgot his first job as a
rocky
astronaut now we always took a nice
close-up picture of the external tank uh
right after moo because if you'll
remember the external tank was the only
part of the Space Shuttle that wasn't
reused you know the boosters would fly
back and or splash down in the ocean
would tow them back in refurbish them
the shuttle would come back but the
external tank as soon as we got off the
tank it would Start Tumbling back to
Earth and break up and and burn up
re-entering the atmosphere and just
splash down in little pieces so we
always wanted to take a nice big
close-up picture of the tank right after
we got off it to see if there was any AB
abnormality with it that might be
generic that we'd need to fix before the
next shuttle took off so my very first
job as a rookie was to as soon as we got
to Mo instantaneously zg was to get on
strap wrapped out of my seat float down
to a locker by me get the proper camera
out float up to the overhead window
while dick Richards the commander on my
first flight was pitching Discovery over
on its back so that we could take a
picture of this tank as it's following
way back to Earth well I floated up to
the overhead window and I'm looking
outside and Dick says hey Bruce you
should be seeing it and I said yeah dick
I do it's awesome it's beautiful he said
well why aren't you taking any pictures
I said pictures of what oh the tank I
was so blown blown away by seeing Earth
for the first time from the space
shuttle that I choked on my first job
and you know I was supposed to have this
great big picture of the tank well by
the time I took a picture of the tank it
was like falling away from us and and
but it was just beautiful it was just I
just seeing the Earth for the first time
from space is you know probably my most
memorable
experience if you don't already have
nebula for a limited time we are
offering lifetime membership a one-off
one-time payment to get lifelong access
to the world's largest creator-owned
streaming service or maybe you have
nebula already and would prefer to
switch over to Lifetime to get away from
reoccurring subscription payments while
helping us accelerate growth of our
platform without taking on Venture
Capital money or you could be a happy
member already and want to gift nebula
to someone special in your life and for
that we also just launched gifted
lifetime subscription
whatever way you decide to sign up you
will be rewarded with exclusive video
series like wover Productions Logistics
of series detailing the logistics of arm
manufacturing search and rescue
commercial fishing and much more or our
own series about the logistics of D-Day
and early access to real engineering
videos without any ads like episode 2 of
the insane engineering of the Space
Shuttle which you can watch right now
normal yearly membership is $30 a year
or you can get the discounted rate of
just 250 a month with the link in the
description